it's been a while since we last explored
any Japanese folklore and today we'll be
taking a look at one of the most iconic
figures the Oni roughly translated Oni
means ogre or demon and they have a
large overbearing figure much taller
than any man the appearance of the Oni
is something that does vary they are
most commonly shown with red or blue
skin with two horns and Fang like tusks
their appearance is not too different
from that of an ogre the number of horns
eyes and fingers along with skin color
is something that does constantly change
depending on the story their clothing as
you would expect from a giant ogre like
creature is quite primitive only were in
the pelts and hides of beasts they have
slain their size would suggest that they
have immense strength and the Oni are
extremely dangerous demons wherever they
go disease and disaster spreads and
follows only were originally once human
but they are born when a truly evil
human dies they are then sent to one of
the many Buddhist Hills where they
eventually transform into an Oni they
were the servants of the Great Lord em
nur ruler of hell
wielding huge iron clubs they would
destroy and crush any human that cross
their path for fun
the only were responsible for punishing
those who were considered evil enough to
be reborn into a demon similar to
themselves their techniques of torture
included crushing bones and peeling off
the skin of their victims
Oh knees were the foot soldiers of
choice for the great generals of the
underworld and there have been occasions
where a human soul is so evil and beyond
any kind of redemption that they
transform into an Oni while still alive
remaining on earth terrorizing the
living these only are the most commonly
referred to in the stories as they were
considered to be the most dangerous
originally the word Oni was used in
Chinese folklore and even some Buddhist
teachings it was used to refer to ghosts
spirits and monsters and it was commonly
used in Chinese to refer to a ghost the
same could be said in early Japanese
folklore before spirits had been
individually categorized only referred
to any supernatural being as spirits
became more defined the definition for
Oni became much more narrow referring to
a specific kind of ogre like demon when
looking into stories regarding the Oni
the one that I kept coming across was
the story of shootin doji shootin doji
was very smart but troubled orphan child
at a very early age he became a monk but
it was a lifestyle that he could not
adapt to he would often get into fights
with the other monks and lacked any kind
of respect for his peers he was lazy and
he would rather spend his time drinking
rather than study in this earned him the
nickname shootin doji meaning little
drunkard during one of the festivals
shootin doji decided that he would play
pranks during the celebration he decided
that he would wear an Oni mask and hide
in the darkness waiting to scare the
festival goers
when the festival was over he attempted
to take off the mask but he could not as
it had fused itself to his face when he
looked for help everyone he asked
refused mocking him and reminding him
what type of person he had been to them
he was full of anger and his heart began
to resemble that of an Oni he left the
monastery and fled to the mountains
where he would live as a hermit now
alone in solitude his hatred and anger
towards the world only grew each day he
began to embrace wickedness and cruelty
study in black magic he would kidnap
young men and women who crossed his path
taken them back to his lair drinking
their blood and devouring their organs
with each passing year he grew stronger
and more violent he had earned the
reputation of true evil and other wicked
individuals flocked to him it wasn't
long before shootin doji had amassed a
small army of demons
he's army grew large enough that it
attracted the attention of the Emperor
who could no longer allow his people to
be ravaged he ordered his most powerful
warrior Reiko to climb the mountain and
bring back the head of shootin doji
Reiko and his men made their way to the
castle of shootin doji where they came
across the army of demons drinkin sake
they managed to poison the sake and the
only fell into a drunken slumber the
sleeping Oni was slain one by one when
they finally reached shootin doji Reiko
swung his sword and sliced off the head
of the demon but shootin doji had grown
so strong that he was not killed his
head continued attempting to bite Reiko
and his men the head was taken somewhere
where no one could find it and buried
where it could no longer cause any more
trouble
the Oni were terrifying figures and some
of the most deadly in Japanese folklore
but over the years they've gone for a
transformation they are now seen as
somewhat of a good-luck charm with only
masks being used to scare away evil
spirits I hope you guys enjoyed the
video if you did then feel free to give
it a thumbs up it was definitely fun
taking another look at Japanese folklore
if you guys have any stories of Oni that
you'd like to share then please do so in
the comments below as always I've been
your host mythology in fiction explained
you